Oh my God everybody that was amazing.
This is going to be my Arrow 100th episode
video.
It's part three of the crossover and the flash
ring giveaway is still going on, what a crazy
100th episode so they did a good job of including
everyone even people that couldn't make it
because of scheduling problems.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet and there is a new round
of the flash ring giveaway going on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to turn alerts on I will be announcing a winner
at the end of this, but let's talk about all
this matrix craziness, so top 10 WTF and comic
book Easter eggs most of the Easter eggs.
They included were for things that they've
done on arrow they were internal Easter eggs,
so they open the episode number 10 Oliver
running through a bunch of trees.
This is like a long-held arrow tradition with
Oliver opening each season like that episode
one with him running through trees into some
other situation but surprised he's in the
backyard of the queen mansion which I'm blown
up between seasons a couple years ago.
So they open the episode completely in dream
land which is in stark contrast to the way
they ended the last episode with them all
getting beamed up after that crazy epic battle
so Stephen Amell actually said very specifically
like he is an actor doesn't get to give notes
lot but they do ask them for input when they
give him scripts like hey you know what you
think of this episode were getting ready to
shoot and every once in a while he'll get
to like throw something in.
He said that like his big thing with the hundredth
episode was that because they were going to
be doing such crazy stuff is that he wanted
the open the episode with music in like a
different way like to do it completely differently
to let you know that this wasn't a normal
episode, so we'll talk about this is that
I work through Easter eggs but like they had
music use like a league of assassins music
you for Sara when she said something about
not being an assassin.
So they were like little bits that they added
just to let you know that this is completely
different, but because of all the height going
into it all the info they been dropping I
think most of us understood that this was
going to be like a special matrix dream land
situation, but number nine speaking of which,
we meet Laura Lantz she is engaged to Oliver
it like in the comics and a lot of people
were probably happy about that.
But as you start saying hello to everyone
he sees his father.
His mother then Thea gives him the hose and
that he gave to her after coming back from
the island in the pilot episode, so they were
like a lot of things happening in this episode
that went all the way back to the pilot, especially
Oliver's father because he died in the pilot,
but number eight back in the real world.
Cisco comes in and has to revive Oliver's
bow to find out that they're all on that ship
and the reverse engineer the dominators technology
with a whole bunch of movie references of
this is my C-3 PO chip oh you make movie references.
That's so lame like Cisco is Mister movie
reference.
So the storyline that was happening outside
of the episode was relatively brief.
Like most of the episode was dedicated to
this arrow storyline because it's the hundredth
episode so you don't like hijack it with a
bunch of other stuff but number eight like
the big Doctor who reference the cyber men
referenced a woman basically grafting technology
onto herself they have to get a piece from
it in order to help the people that are trapped
on the spaceship Barry and Kara team up with
the rest of team arrow with a whole bunch
of jokes about Barry carrying people like
pretty much every funny moment that they've
had where flash crosses over with arrow characters
like Diggle freaking out and throwing up every
time Barry carries them they tried to touch
on that they also had this arc with wild dog
kind of coming around on metahuman's like
I don't trust you.
You make things worse but by the end of the
episode.
They were completely cool so you know number
seven Barry and Kara versus the cyber woman
just total tagteam it was awesome just like
the brief amount of those characters that
you needed just to remember that there's like
larger stuff going on besides the arrow matrix
hundredth episode stuff, so number six meet
Sara in the dreamland she touches laurels
Canary necklace.
So, what a coincidence she starts remember
things Oliver starts to have flashes he catches
the vase he notices the smoke technologies
building.
They have a very Batman moment where they
almost get mugged in the alley.
But there say by mystery green arrow all wonder
that was but Oliver's father gives in this
big speech about doing the responsible thing
hey take over or is queen consolidated CO
hooks keep in the family.
I'm getting ready to run for mayor so the
touching on storylines from back in season
one his father starts talking about the work
that he's doing isn't finished yet, which
was one of the final lines that he told to
Oliver before he died Oliver just been sworn
in as mayor so basically like all the conversations
they're having in all the Easter eggs are
all blends of everything that's ever happened
on arrow throw like mixing and matching things.
But the more Oliver starts talking to people
the more he touches things sees really like
significant things from his past he starts
to freak out have hallucinations of what really
happened sees visions of Laurel his father
his mother dying and then number five when
he goes to see Quentyn was a really funny
speech does not seem like a broken down alcoholic
says Oliver's like a really great person,
despite him not being super hot on them before.
So he goes to where the current arrow cave
is sees it as it is currently in present-day
with the addition of a giant firm in frame
right next to Felicity and in swings the green
arrow intruder alert, it's Diggle the last
time I think we saw Diggle in the green arrow
costume was during season three before Oliver
got like his big suit upgrade, so Diggle is
in full crazy mode he hasn't like woken up
to the fact that he's in a matrix he speaking
to Oliver in a version of Stephen Amell's
arrow voice which it it itself is kind of
a version of Batman voice, so Diggle Batman
voice was kind of funny but the five people
that are in the matrix.
Just remember is Oliver Diggle Sara Thea and
Ray Palmer.
So eventually they all start to come together
like buses are touching each other they start
to remember they figured out number four they're
going to try and keep us trapped in here like
Diggle pulls out the picture of the dominator
in surprise surprise deathstroke appear just
whips his sword out is one of the greatest
introductions ever so I don't think that the
new Bennett was underneath that mast, otherwise
he would've torn it off.
They would've had him on screen.
But just like Tommy.
I think that the new Bennett was unavailable
because he himself is a series regular on
a couple of other shows.
So just like no way they could make it work
so they found a way to make deathstroke work,
but Sara comes in and saves them because like,
Oliver hasn't quite fully remembered that
he's a really bad ass fighter like it takes
a most of the episode to figure everything
out like okay we have to get out of here,
but number three the wedding reception.
So this is funny we had the Thea Merlin moment
where they totally name dropped Tommy, who
is a mysterious doctor in Chicago could not
make it.
The funny thing about this like if you don't
know Collin Donnell the actor who played Tommy
is a series regular on Chicago med he plays
a doctor on that show.
So this was the writers saying that Tommy
couldn't come to Oliver and Laurel's wedding
reception because he's a doctor on another
show like a just laughing about that but then
Laurel makes a joke about Sara hooking up
with Oliver.
All you know I'm a lesbian, but you know that
Sara in season one was on the Queen's gambit
hooking up with Oliver, so to Oliver says
is really tearful goodbye to his mother, father,
and then the team tries to leave and has to
fight off the combined forces of deathstroke.
Malcolm Merlin is the dark archer Damien Darhk
in one of the mirror crew soldiers.
So Oliver puts another arrow through deathstroke's
eyes just a little Easter egg from season
one and from season to when he did it to Slade
Wilson and I was really happy that they gave
Oliver that final goodbye moment where he
seeing the visions of all the people that
are most important to him just kind of reassuring
him that the decisions he's made were the
right ones is a good person just even like
the bump that he needs and they find a way
to include footage of Tommy and Roy who could
not make it for the episode.
I was kind of bummed that they weren't around
for the producers explained that which is
like no way they could make it work with those
actors schedule so that of about or maybe
sometime in the back half Colton can come
back I definitely think that Tommy and Roy
will come back for an episode in the future
it just depends on when they're available
and whatever story does they want to bring
them back for all that talk does throw a lot
of water on the idea that Tommy might be Prometheus.
So if Collin Donnell was so busy that he could
not make it for the Arrow 100th episode that
I think it be really hard for him to be a
big villain in the back half of the season
as Prometheus, but number one they escape
and the team learns that the dominators language
is based on Hebrew or lease that shares a
lot in common with Hebrew just because the
show is trying to tease that there is like
a larger Galactic community and they share
a lot in common like humans are not this singular
thing they're part of this giant organism
that is the universe with many races that
we will hopefully eventually meet now that
kinda gets in the Green Lantern really big
space-based stuff this idea that they share
a lot in common with the aliens will come
back later.
This is then just laying sees the kind of
doing more the stuff.
On Supergirl, but Mr. terrific has that line
about not wanting to turn it into a religious
thing, there is a God in the DC universe that
takes a couple of different forms he's known
as the presence he gets used a lot in Lucifer
Neil Gaiman stories he doesn't appear a whole
lot in the main DC comics just because it's
really hard to tell a story when a character
is completely invincible like Superman seems
invincible but he does have weaknesses.
So it just makes it almost impossible to write
a story with conflict about a character that
can't be beaten.
So that's why you don't see God a whole lot
in the DC universe but he's also known as
the source the place where the new gods get
their powers from.
So when they talk about divine plan that is
kind of hinting at new gods stuff like that
like bigger or larger Green Lantern Galactic
stuff happening, but I will say this is my
favorite arrow episode in his long as I can
remember.
I felt like they did a really good job of
hitting beats with each of the characters
they give Thea that really nice moment with
Moira Oliver got really nice moments with
his parents Dale got really nice moments with
Laurel.
So I like the way they wrote the characters,
the interactions the sentiment.
So now my head is spinning a little bit as
to how the gonna bring Laurel back in the
back half of the season because that still
like a completely separate thing.
What talk about that after the midseason finale
because I don't think were gonna learn about
that till Talley all cool and Laurel come
back in episode 10 supposedly they'll be Laurel
stuff in episode 10, but there is definitely
Talia stuff happening, but I think that's
mostly for the flashbacks.
So just a heads up.
The next part of the crossover is legends
of tomorrow like they get saved by the WaveRider.
So obviously they'll pick up with that.
In tomorrow's episode so hopefully if I can
get it out in time I'll do and arrow up finale
trailer video like an arrow episode nine trailer
video for the Prometheus stuff then I'll do
Rick and Morty, which I meant to do today
and then I'll do my legends video but I'll
say congratulations to the current giveaway
winner night will you win the first flash
ring, so I'll announce the next winner when
I post my legends video tomorrow so I'll just
remind people about the giveaway when I post
a DC video so no worries if you guys are behind
on the crossover.
I will add links for the other crossover videos
that I've done at the end of this what you
guys wait for that to post you can click here
for next week's flash trailer it's totally
crazy and you can click here for part two
of the crossover, thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight!